oh just you just a high-five for you I
don't know this man who's this man
what's your name
J that's my father's name no way
J Holmes JJ if you're nasty J you want
to read the first card where's that
first card we don't have a welcome to
the show card J come read this with me
this is Jay look some of America this is
the card I have to read every show
this is Teddy our cue card guy and he
has to hold that up for me every time
but I get tired of reading why don't you
do it he's let's do it however you want
thank you hello everybody welcome to the
feed Home Show
I think that that's good I think we're
gonna Holly
Thank You Jay that's all we're after
just a different just a different way to
start is we're all just uh I just want
to feel something I hate the feeling of
beginning so you get Jay up here please
how you like leave Jail whoa I didn't
mean it that way but see that's good if
you felt a little like hey I like those
moments life moments where you feel
something that's what we're after on the
show that happens to me all the time
it's strange the things that will make
things like bubble up inside of you
that's kind of my point like let me tell
you this I had dinner the other night
ordered a hamburger got a hamburger
waitress has this magical exchange with
me she goes would you like fries salad
or tater tots and that's all it took I
was like lady the you think I want I
want the thing that's almost never an
option
tater tots baby that's all the Tuck and
I was experiencing intense emotion
that's how I am I'm always flying off
with emotion I'm not like dangerous not
like a basket case it's not like I just
saw Pete laughing and crying at the same
time going over and over about how he
was gonna teach us a lesson that's not
me
what I'm saying is I just allow emotions
to flow through me cuz that's what it
means to be a human like I love a good
cry whoo-oop I'm you're ready to cry
love a cry it's like throwing up for
your soul cleanser so let it fly easy
YouTube videos of babies laughing
kittens blinking their eyes open
children's choirs children ohh hoo boy
see a children's choir summon battlin
hmm I can't handle it and I don't want
to handle it and I think I cry because
it's the sound of innocence that's what
it is
I haven't yet been contaminated by the
world here's some of the older singers
here in Bob Seger's voice you can tell
by his vocal cords the guy's seen a few
rough nights it's in there like how much
for the whole bag feeling a bit against
the winds the children singing beautiful
when it's done right don't get me wrong
it can be terrifying I felt some of you
feeling like no that's scary it can be
all the children working together
bleached white robes you know what I
mean you're just watching like nice nice
nice are they gonna murder the town
Oh who taught the children in the corner
harmonized I guess my point is weird
things get me emotional I get that from
my dad I've never seen my dad cry like
in real life he's like a man's man he's
tough he drives an oil truck eats tuna
fish no mayo you know straight cam I'm
so not tough those are what my examples
are of being tough look at that guy with
the chicken of the sea
but he's a man's man he doesn't cry as
my point until you popping a VHS of the
natural that's all it takes and
something's like Robert Redford he's so
good at baseball I'm the same way movies
are a huge trigger for me for me avatar
you know that scene with a Navi or two
you Philistines the blue people at scene
at the end well they all come together
to save the dying tree who waterworks
crying grown man crying I didn't cry
when my wife left me
what take blue animal people standing
around a fake tree on a fake planet
suddenly I'm crying like I should have
when my wife left baby it can be
something small like olives I've had
emotional experiences over olives it's
true pop in the first olive of many
let's not kid ourselves it's gonna be a
lot love a good olive throwing the first
all but I don't yet know this olive is
this Oliver have a pit I don't trust the
bite I don't like I don't know what I'm
gonna do so I'm scared I go and cautious
like a stray dog it doesn't quite trust
your hand of dry food
it's olives but then suddenly I realize
not only does this all have not have a
Pitt there's actually a pimento in there
too am I the chosen one that all it
might as well have been filled with
pickle joy I thought it was gonna have
to do that stupid choo around the pit
like a beaver move but nope instead I
get to enjoy a pimento that weird red
delicious thing that nobody knows the
origin of is it a pepper is it an onion
who cares
savor the mystery in that moment the
universe has your back but what I'm
trying to say is don't back away from
the big feelings they're not just for
weddings birthdays or holidays let it
out whenever the mood hits you feel damn
it
feet why because you're alive because
you're you because you call the shots
when you get that tingly hot feeling in
your cheeks and pins and needles down
your spine don't shake it off don't go
and be a robot jump into the deep end of
your humanity and say with pride with
tears in your eyes you're right I'll
have the tater tots